with millions of credit card purchases
daily detecting fraudulent transactions
before they can complete is more
important than ever I'm Billy Jacobson a
developer Advocate with a focus on cloud
databases and in this video we'll look
at how we can use big data processing
tools machine learning endpoints and the
low latency and highly scalable bigtable
database to detect fraud in milliseconds
thank you
[Music]
when a customer initiates a credit card
purchase the transaction is sent for
processing before the purchase can be
completed the system needs to validate
the credit card check for fraud and then
add it to the customer's transaction
history once the result is in the
transaction can be completed if no fraud
was detected otherwise the customer
might receive a fraud alert and can
block any further transactions until
their account can be secured all of
these actions are happening during a
customer's checkout flow so we need to
ensure low latency processing to provide
a smooth experience for millions of
shoppers
let's look at how we can create a
scalable system that supports this use
case the first step towards detecting
fraud is managing the stream of customer
transactions we need an event streaming
service that can horizontally scale to
meet the workload traffic so Cloud Pub
sub is a great choice I can simulate a
transaction by sending a pub sub message
with the user ID timestamp transaction
ID price merchant ID Merchant
geolocation and then a question mark to
indicate the fraud status in real life
we just do this programmatically using
the client libraries Pub sub has a
built-in integration with Google Cloud's
data pipeline tool Cloud dataflow let's
look at my transaction pipeline in the
dataflow UI this will allow us to
process the stream of transactions at
scale
to determine if a transaction is fraud
we'll compare the pending transaction
with the customer's historical
transaction patterns and their user
profile
we're using bigtable as a feature store
here with column families or customer
transaction history and user profile
bigtable is highly scalable and has
consistent single digit millisecond
latency so there's less time used for
fetching data and more time available
for processing data
before we developed our pipeline we used
machine learning to train a fraud
detection model based on our transaction
history and then use vertex AI endpoints
to deploy the model to a managed service
vertex AI supports custom models
developed on any framework and has
built-in tooling to track our model's
performance
now with our Pipeline and model deployed
we'll send our pending transaction
historical data and user profile to the
model and receive our prediction back
which we've outputted to the worker logs
the fraud probability on this one is low
awesome we can let the transaction
complete
with this prediction in hand we send it
to a pub sub output stream the credit
card processing can complete if no fraud
was detected or we could send a push
notification to let the customer know
there is a fraud attempt on their
account
we also can write the new transaction to
bigtable so it can be used as a data
point for future transactions bigtable
scales horizontally for reading and
writing data so keeping our feature
store up to date is as easy as querying
it this is a simplified example of a
fraud detection system we use tools with
horizontal scalability to ensure our
system is prepared for when we go from
thousands of customers to Millions
during a big event and we have a low
latency database keeping our checkout
flow running smoothly at any scale
if you're interested in deploying this
solution yourself you can find links to
the code source with a terraform setup
in the description we'll link to more
resources on Raw detection for you to
read further thanks for watching
[Music]